el ahorro del futuro para superar la
crisis del presente el cuarto retiro
anticipado del 10% de las pensiones en
chile ahora está en manos del senado
tras pasar la prueba en la cámara de
diputados- este nuevo proyecto como está
planteado permitiría retirar la
totalidad del ahorro en caso de
enfermedades catastróficas también
autoriza la retención de fondos a
deudores de pensiones alimenticias y
estará libre de impuestos pero aunque
chile es uno de los pioneros no es el
único varios países de américa latina
han dejado que sus ciudadanos echen mano
de su ahorro previsional una polémica
iniciativa que pretende aliviar los
bolsillos diezmados por la pandemia pero
que pone a analistas y autoridades
económicas en alerta los implica en la
práctica que cuando llegue el momento
del retiro de esas personas el valor de
las pensiones van a ser más bajos lo
cual es un problema grande ya sabemos
los líos que han habido en países de
américa latina incluyendo el mismo chile
en términos de las expectativas que
tenían las personas cuando llegaban a su
edad de adulto mayor para recibir unas
pensiones bastante altas que al final
haciendo pensiones ajustadas a la baja
por unas menores rentabilidades frente a
lo esperado entonces lo que va a hacer
esto estos retiros digamos de alguna
manera el producto de la panda es
justamente profundizar ese problema
reducir el monto de las pensiones pero
ha autorizado dos retiros y bolivia
promulgó una ley similar mientras que
naciones como colombia y méjico alguna
vez lo han contemplado sin éxito alguno